well first of all how are you doing
being trapped inside with your daughter
Mike's daughters Mike everybody's in one
house and all girlfriend okay we somehow
inherited so how am i doing with one man
and three other females it is been a
learning lesson we've had to have a
couple of different house meetings we
had to lay down some ground rules we had
just you know make short assignments
because apparently they think that they
don't have to do anything except eat all
the food sleep all day and make take
tops of course you're going to come into
this house and you are going to clean
and if anything come up missing in my
house I promise you you won't come up
missing I think we've made some pretty
impressive take tops I'm just saying I
haven't seen everybody else know about
anything why wouldn't you have a banter
with me that's my point that it's like
you're in your feelings but beyond Andy
what was the question she said that she
didn't like it that you said I was but I
got busy so Kelly and Ashley they were
like well or does that Mike do it
so Mike just stepped in for me little
did I know he was going to kill it I
don't think I could have ever done it as
well as he did so you know God doesn't
make mistakes I mean is this testing
your relationship at all no time apart
oh for sure this is the ultimate test
right now because here's the thing if we
get into an argument and I get mad at
Mike about something normally the old
before the coronavirus quarantine
Cynthia Bailey would go check in a hotel
I'd be like you know what no sand snake
I would go and dry myself from Porter
Ranch debrife Lee Hillson kicked myself
into a nice little hotel and beat me now
I have to still sleep in the same bed in
the same house and I'm just happy to go
out for any reason at this point but
yeah things have changed pressure
definitely been tested but you know it's
kind of forced us to this is kind of
like what it would really be like to be
married and like work from home together
like I take my hat off to anyone who is
married and work at home every day and
see their partner every single day
because you guys have to realize Mike
and I are no long distance relationship
and even if we weren't with both of our
careers I travel a lot to work and so
does he so we don't see each other every
single day morning noon night breakfast
lunch and dinner
but now we see each other we good well
you guys had teas that you are thinking
of a 10 10 20 wedding date has this
whole situation put any snags and
planning well we've had to really think
about it a little bit we did speak with
our wedding planner to see what our
options were in case we had to postpone
it I'll move the date bag because quite
honestly you know at this point we don't
know when you know we don't know what's
going on we don't know when people are
going to be able to go back to work or
if they're going to be able to go back
to work even if they still have jobs I
don't know if people will be able you
know a lot of my friends are from out of
town I don't know if they'll be able to
afford to come at this point like I just
really don't know and or even be in the
spirit to go like this has been a very I
mean hopefully people are gonna come out
and want to celebrate and just go every
everywhere they can go but I really
don't know Bryce it's kind of concerning
because we still have the date holding
but we did speak to the venue and our
wedding planner to see what our options
were if we needed to move it back
because we all know what's more now we
can't even know it so I can even worry
about Nick ceasing it we just I'm just
trying to get past the reunion whenever
we get today
[Music]